sans surprise si j'ai une Ping a été élu
à la tête du parti communiste pour 5
années supplémentaires le président
chinois va aussi débuter un troisième
mandat présidentiel dans quelques mois
alors que la presse commence à filmer
avant le vote un homme attrape par le
bras l'ancien président rougeintao assis
à côté de son successeur Shein ping
l'homme essaie de le soulever mais
rouges hintao semble réticent il tente
d'attraper des documents que chez inping
retient
enfin que pour la toute première fois
depuis 25 ans le Bureau politique ne
compte comme vous le voyez aucune femme
accepte finalement de se lever toujours
escorté
il adresse deux mots au numéro un
chinois qui lui répond sans le regarder
c'est un drôle de moment pour venir
parler de la paix
et donc je me suis d'abord demandé chez
Andrea si vous étiez vraiment un ami
une fille qui vient de renommer réélire
je ne sais pas comment on doit dire si
j'ai une pin pour 5 ans à nouveau avec
un parti communiste chinois qui va être
encore plus dur plus à gauche lui fermer
sur lui-même les États-Unis qui
n'hésitent pas à jouer leur carte
souvent un peu en solitaire
Meloni à Rome au palais kyrinal la
nouvelle présidente du conseiller
italien qui a aujourd'hui prêté serment
à part composé son nouveau gouvernement
à ses côtés en tiendra deux visages
celui de Silvio Berlusconi et celui de
Matteo Salvini et reprenons Molière je
me suis dit qu'est-ce que je suis allé
faire dans cette galère
l'hôpital fait face à une épidémie de
bronchiolite cette infection virale qui
qui infecte les poumons des petits
nourrissons et qui les amènent
fréquemment à l'hôpital elle intervient
tôt dans l'année et donc on va
déclencher on déclenche là où c'est
nécessaire les fameux plan blanc un plan
d'action de 150 millions d'euros pour
répondre tout de suite à des
problématiques spécifiques de certains
secteurs c'est à dire quoi ouverture de
lier augmentation personnelle
augmentation de personnel c'est
essentiellement cela à condition que
l'on trouve du personnel pour être
adopté une motion de censure doit être
votée par au moins 289 députés la
majorité absolue elle aurait pour effet
de provoquer la démission du
gouvernement mais même en s'unissant RN
et nupes aurait besoin de voix de
députés les républicains or dans cette
tribune publiée hier 53 des 62 députés
LR on revendiqué leur refus de s'allier
avec les oppositions s'il n'y a pas de
motion de censure et si les groupes ne
votent pas leur motion de censure ou une
autre ça veut dire qu'en fait ils
accorde leur responsabilité au
gouvernement donc elle est un soutien
Elisabeth bien sûr à partir du
si vous voulez n'assument pas leur
responsabilité voilà moi j'espère que en
Ukraine Vladimir Poutine va s'inspirer
de votre quinquennat François Hollande
et va bah rien faire
alors
l'ancien président de la République qui
nous donne son avis sur le début du
second mandat d'Emmanuel Macron et qui
réaffirme un son soutien à l'actuel chef
de l'État j'ai été très transparent
pendant la campagne présidentielle je
l'ai soutenu et si c'était à refaire je
le referai
finalement un déchaînement contre vous
présidente Nicolas Sarkozy se permet
quelques conseils à Emmanuel Macron et
notamment salié au Républicain
j'aimerais parfois qu'il franchisse le
Rubicon de façon plus franche car la
France est aujourd'hui clairement du
parti de l'autorité de la fermeté et de
la liberté est-ce que on peut on ne peut
pas protéger efficacement les Français
et prendre des mesure utile de
transformation sans coalition moi je
crois pas la preuve Bruno retaille au
chef de fil des sénateurs LR au Sénat et
candidat à la présidence du parti s'y
oppose clairement je ne partage pas son
diagnostic Emmanuel Macron n'est pas à
droite on n'est pas à droite quand on
aime pas peine d'y aller à l'éducation
nationale quand on ne tient ni la rue ni
les comptes ni les frontières voilà
comment on enfourche ça monture lorsque
l'on est un spécialiste du VTT freeride
on ne faites pas ça avec un Vélib'
surtout le but du jeu c'est d'enchaîner
les figures sur ces lignes de crête
ponctuées de plusieurs sauts au-dessus
d'un canyon de plus de 12 mètres de
profondeur